Good morning
Believe nation its Evan my one word is believe and I believe in you I believe in your potential and I want to see that
Thing that you've got inside you come out so you can have a positive impact on yourself on your family your community and the world
So to help you on your journey today's message is dream big
over to you Steve Jobs I
Think that as
You know right now the computer industry is in the tank
Personal computers big computers everything and it's difficult
it's a difficult time, but I'm sure that Henry Ford had a few bad quarters back in the 1920s and
The automobile had a sort of historical imperative it had the minute
It was invented a sequence of events had to happen
The same is true with the personal computer. There is a tremendous
Momentum behind this and I think that this year may be a delay this year we may look back and say well
1985 was a slow year
But there is such momentum behind this that it will happen it will
permeate and change forever our educational processes and
My hope again is that?
Not too many generations of students will pass through before this happens
It will happen within 20 years it probably will happen within 10 years
But it could happen within five years
I am going back to the United States this weekend and then about two weeks from today
I'll be in the Soviet Union for the first time in Moscow because one of my dreams has been to sell
Macintosh's in the Soviet Union
And one of the highest agenda agendas Amaya priority is to
Is to get them starting to think about exactly the same thing so maybe
Six months or a year year and a half from now we can have some
Soviet schools here at our
Your a consortium meeting
It can be hard to keep perspective when you hit a rough patch
It can be hard to stay sane and stay motivated and stay
optimistic
When you fall on tough times when something doesn't go right when the market slows down when you lose a big customer and that's part
Of the game of being an entrepreneur we're gonna have these highs and lows
But hopefully we're moving forward in the positive direction and part of winning as an entrepreneur is just sticking with it
It's just staying on the path. It's just everyday getting up and being consistent and moving forward
You only really lose if you give up right and so you can lose little battles
But if you keep going you're gonna win the war and I think what really helps you keep?
Consistent and keep motivated and keep on every day getting up and fighting is
Remembering the wives remembering your big dream the big goal what you're trying to accomplish and so for me. I think about
Untapped potential you know I think the biggest problem in the world is
Untapped human potential. I think if we can solve that we solve all the major problems of the world
And I think the way to help untap people or help to unlock them help bring out that potential is through the environment
Right you may not have that with your friends and your family your parents the people around you
But you can get that from the books and videos and the resources that you watching consume
And so it's why I created this YouTube channel
So what keeps me motivated on a daily basis is?
Thinking about that big problem the biggest problem the world is facing is
Untapped human potential and if I can create content
That slowly moves people forward slowly
Helps unlock a little bit of potential if you keep hearing the same message multiple times from different people
Slowly it starts to seep in right the more time you spend around successful people
The more you want to become successful the more you adopt their mindset and positivity and the more you hang around
people who are not accomplishing things who are complaining and who are negative the more you're gonna be like those people and
So my solution is to create that for you for myself
I want to be around uber successful people and have their mindset seep into me
And so whenever things don't go my way whenever a series doesn't work out whenever something happens
You know life is gonna happen problems are gonna happen in business
It's never just a straight line up whenever those things happen in my business people often asked. Well. How do you stay optimistic?
How do you study you stay go on? How are you so positive all the time?
What's because I believe in where we're going right like I have a big dream? I want to help a billion entrepreneurs
I want to help unlock potential and I believe that the way to do it is through the environment and so
Even though this one thing didn't work out. It's not everything
Right it's being able to step out from the trees to see the forest to see the big picture
So it may have lost one battle
But I'm still fighting the war
And I'm gonna have an impact and I'm gonna make a difference and so just reminding myself of the why what I'm trying to accomplish?
Why I'm doing it
That gets me fired up again to overcome whatever short term
Hassles or problems that I'm facing and so the question of the day. I have for you is what is your big dream?
What's the thing that gets you excited that keeps you motivated that keeps you working hard every day even when you might lose a battle
Share it down the counsel below
I'm excited to see it
And I think writing it down can help you
You know remember why you're doing this and could also potentially inspire the other people watching to help them chase their dreams as well
So share it down the comments below. I also want to give a quick shout out to Henry Kaminski jr. Henry
Thank you so much for picking up a copy of my book through one word
I really really appreciate the support, and I hope you enjoyed the read so thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one word is
Much love, and I'll see you again tomorrow morning for another shot of espresso
Expresso give me go
It's so easy to solve a local problem you need to dream bigger
Over and over again we hear ideas that are interesting in a local context, but they're not big enough
It's a dream bigger right as a general statement about society
We need to ask the harder questions, and we need to ask for stronger solutions
There is a global emerging consensus around issues and so forth together. We're very strong
It's important to me to have the balls to look at the biggest problems
We face as a society and say that's my problem to solve right obesity
metabolic disease
The slide towards ill health however you want to categorize it. That's my problem like I don't even wake up thinking
That's my business partners problem. That's my problem. I'm working with my business partners because of very sharp guys
Yeah, but at the end of the day like I own that responsibility and that's awesome to me right like having that
It isn't a weight that drags me down. It's like this goal to chase. That's so big that
I'm just stoked that there are people in the world debt are prepared to dream that big like I'm inspired by that in others and
Hopefully can inspire other people with our dream and the first and foremost
important thing about running your own race is dreaming big and
here, I'm called back to my childhood when I was just starting elementary school at that point in time the Capri McCourt had just
Ruled that public school districts could pursue desegregation by using forced busing to achieve racial balance in their schools in
Fact I started my own education as a first grader being bused to a school across
Town even though my father was a principal at a school five blocks away
Although I was a live subject in one of the nation's most controversial legal debates
I frankly didn't know what the big deal was all about because
These kids who didn't look like me sure acted just like me
But desegregation was a big deal to my parents and leaders of their
generations knew a great knew that great change was in store
and it was the right thing to do and they often met with resistance and
often violent resistance
But because of their struggle their sacrifice. I received a great gift and
That's the gift to dream
I
Knew my history
I remembered the pride of my mother telling about when she took me and my brother
Brought us back to Washington DC. And held me as a nine-month-old
During the march on Washington when Martin Luther King laid out his dream for equal and harmonious meritocratic America
And dreaming big to me meant knowing my history, but not being bound by it it
Meant harnessing the past to drive me into the future it meant grounding myself, and who I was and where I came from so
I could soar to become who I wanted to become
If you had to think of one word
That's most important to you or that sums you up or that would be like a little beacon
Hey believe nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details